le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
accéder à l'emploi lorsque l'on est en
situation de handicap une mission trop
souvent impossible malgré la législation
française qui impose un quota aux
employeurs peu d'entreprises respectent
la loi
depuis 2013 le département s'efforce de
montrer l'exemple en recrutant plus de
personnes en situation de handicap
karine 30 ans est agent au conseil
départemental depuis quatre ans
[Musique]
de madeleine karine 20h45 c'est de ping
ma naissance j'ai toujours vécu avec
pour moi ça me
gène pas 7h30 comme tous les matins
karine se rendent au travail dans son
propre véhicule
avant je me mettais des pauvreté le
matin et 9 fois pour rentrer chez moi je
connais ne
aujourd'hui la jeune femme est autonome
grâce à sa volonté et à quelques
aménagements dans sa voiture c'est me
permet de tourner plus facilement et
mame ngor tu me permets
tu nous faisais ne saigne à temps car il
souffre d'infirmité motrice depuis 30
ans un handicap qui ne l'a jamais
empêché de vivre ni même de travailler
c'est d'ailleurs son employeur qui l'a
aidé à financer son permis de conduire
et sa voiture depuis quatre ans car il
travaille au département à saint denis
après une scolarité classique
la jeune femme a enchaîné les formations
ses habits petite enfance bep
secrétariat formation d'agent
administratif
malgré ses qualifications le département
est le premier employeur à lui donner sa
chance
j'étais en finir une candidature pour
l'année au sein du département rende mon
entretien clash est très bien parti
j'estime est mais mes compétences en
avant leveaux même
de par ma à très beau signer mon contrat
karine et gestionnaires à la cellule
approvisionnement son vol effectué des
commandes de fournitures pour les agents
de toute l'île il faut savourer son
travail et l infobourg patient et avoir
vraiment la volonté
de faire de la volonté ce petit bout de
femme en regorge elle travaille
actuellement 26 heures par semaine ans
et huit contrats uniques d'insertion
son objectif obtenir un cdi à temps
plein ou bien gentiment très bien avec
humour qui aime travailler et rennais
marais l'emploi de personnes handicapées
est une obligation depuis 1985 selon la
loi
tout employeur ayant au moins 20
salariés doit compter 6 % de personnes
en situation de handicap parmi ses
effectifs depuis 2013
le département mène un plan de
recrutement pour intégrer plus de
personnes handicapées parmi ses agents
le département est chef de file
l'ensemble des collectivités dans la
prise en charge du handicap et je veux
que le département donne le bon exemple
nous avons déjà à développer
l'information l'information pour bien
faire comprendre aux chefs d'entreprise
et aux opérateurs économiques que le
handicap ne doit pas être source
d'exclusion compteur que ces entreprises
ont beaucoup à gagner aussi à intégrer
de l'effectif des personnes ces
personnes comme tout un chacun mérite de
la considération et cette considération
passe par leur inclusion dans le monde
du travail
une inclusion réussi pour karine grâce à
la volonté politique de son employeur
mais aussi à la détermination de la
jeune femme
ça m'a fait un élan du coeur qu'on veut
c'est un dans mon avis qu'on est motivé
et on est comme la perf et ne va ni
condamnés même toit en france depuis
la loi impose aux entreprises d'au moins
20 salariés l'emploi de personnes en
situation de handicap à hauteur de 6% de
leur effectif total en cas de non
respect de la législation
l'employeur doit verser une compensation
financière aux organismes qui se
consacre à l'insertion professionnelle
des personnes handicapées à la réunion
en 2016 seul 4,75 % de travailleurs en
situation de handicap était employé dans
la fonction publique et -2 4% dans le
secteur privé
le département lui est passé de 84
agents en 2012 à 2 185 aujourd'hui il a
atteint deux taux légal de 6 %
pour plus de renseignements rendez vous
sur le site du département au
www.transgene.fr
[Musique]